[موسيقى]
يعني يا عبير يعني الواحده بتعتبر زوجها
حبيبها ونصفها الثاني تحترموا وتقدروا هل
يمكن ان تعتبروا فرعون صغير
المقصود من كلمه فرعون صغير ايه هي تفخيم
الزوج واعتباره حاجه وقيمه كبيره جدا جدا
في حياتنا وما نسالهاش الكلمه اللي هي
قالتها برده ان الزوج احد النعم من ربنا
علينا فعلا الزوج نعمه كبيره جدا جدا على
زوجته بخصوصا لما يكون زوج صالح واب صالح
لاولاده بيقوم على رعايه بيته وبيهتم بكل
تفاصيله همم انا شايفه ان الكلام بتاعها
هو كلام مستساخ جدا جدا وكلنا مع الرئيس
بتاعها اكيد
بعيدا بعيدا عن يعني استاذ احمد خليني اخذ
الجانب الاخر قبل قليل يعني سهاما فقدت ان
المراه
[موسيقى]
لما تروح وهو يروح احنا دلوقتي الدنيا غير
الاول تمام
يعني دلوقتي الست بتشتغل فيه ستات بتشتغل
12 ساعه وفي ستات بتشتغل 24 ساعه على
ودكتوره انا انا بعد ما تخلص يوم ده كله
ومروحه مش قادره تقف عليك رجلي ده فين
المنطق كده يعني بقى يا سيدي
يروح 100 سنه يعني هي حابه تعمل له اذا
كان برضاها وحبا منها نرفضه ليه احنا
مجتمعنا
هي هي حابه تعمل هي حبه تعمل لجوزها احنا
بنعترض ليه لو هي حابه تعمل لو هي حابه
تعمل لكن انا ما اطلعش على الميديا اقول
تعمل ده عبير ايه رايك
الزوجه هي الزوجه كانت طبيبه كانت دكتوره
كانت وزيره كانت رئيسه وزراء الزوجه هي
الزوجه المهم بتاعتها ما بتتقسمش والمهام
بتاعتها ما بنغفلش بجانب عن جانب وما
بيجيش على بيتنا وزوجنا على حسابنا لو هي
مش قادره توفق ما بين الاثنين يبقى تقعد
في بيتها بيتها اولى بها وجوزها واسرتها
اولى بها مهمه الست الرئيسيه في الحياه هي
الزوج والاسره والاولاد والتربيه والنشا
مش مهمتها انها تشتغل وتجيب فلوس لان ديت
مهمه الزوج ولو هناخذ باعتبار ان ممكن اي
حد يغسل له يديه زي ما حد رجليه زي ما
حضرتك بتقول كده فالبيوتي سنتر موجود
والكوافيرات موجودين والاماكن اللي موجوده
ومتوفره انما مهمه الزوجه اتجاه زوجها ما
حدش ثاني هيقوم بها غيرها هي بس ولو هو حس
منها عدم الاهتمام وعدم الرغبه في التواصل
معه بالشكل اللي هو يرتديه اكيد هيتجوز
عليها لان دوت برده حلال ربنا والراجل له
ان هو يتجوز مثنى وثلاث ورباع والست اللي
تريحه هو اللي هيعيش معها بقيه عمره مش
هيضطر واحده ابدا
[موسيقى]
بتقول حلال ربنا ان هو يتزوج عليها مع
حلال ربنا برده ان هو يعملها كويس ان هو
يحترمها ما هي الست ديت لو نزلت تشتغل
بتشتغل ليه مش عشان عيب مستوى افضل
لاولادها عشان مستوى افضل لبيتها ما هي
الحياه تعاون يا جماعه ما هي الحياه عمرها
ما بتمشي على لاين واحد دلوقتي غير زمان
زمان
عنده محل عطاره بيقف قدامه امين قاعده في
البيت لو نزلت كل ما يدخل البيت
والدتي بتحترم والدي احترام مبالغ فيه
عمرها ما ما ما غسلت رجله ولا الجو ده
والاحترام والتقدير اساس كل العالم
بتلك الامور خالص